signs of hope because since we launched
our emergency omicron appeal on sunday
night a great national fight back has
begun and people have responded with an
amazing spirit of duty and obligation to
others and i want to say that each and
every one of you who rolls up your
sleeve to get jabbed
is helping this national effort and i
want to thank everyone who has come
forward whether you've had to cue around
the block at a walk-in center or whether
you've booked online
and of course on behalf of the whole
country i want to thank our nhs our gps
our pharmacists who with barely a day's
notice 48 hours notice has so
accelerated the program that we began
this week with the biggest vaccination
monday ever in england and yesterday
the biggest booster day yet with more
than 650 000 boosters delivered across
the whole uk and across the country
after all they've been through
those teams are going to keep going
through christmas and beyond
jab heroes like kim kirk leading the
king's mill hospital vaccination hub in
mansfield who was asked a year ago to do
it for four weeks and has been doing it
ever since
with 180 000 jabs
and counting
dr laura mount and the team at central
and west warrington primary care network
who've been organizing pop-up
vaccination clinics for the homeless
or the team at home park in plymouth who
have been regularly jabbing until 2 a.m
because they just carry on for as long
as there are people there wanting a
booster
and
i want to thank
those from every walk of life who are
stepping forward to support them the
military personnel deployed across every
region of the country including an
additional 100 in scotland from
yesterday as well as 2 500 firefighters
and since sunday night we've seen more
than 20 000 new volunteers signing up to
help with the booster effort as stewards
taking the total number to almost 33 000
with every day we're expanding the ranks
of these healthcare auxiliaries an
emerging territorial army of the nhs in
a race against time to get those jabs in
arms and save lives and if you're
watching this
and you want to get involved just visit
the website nhs
volunteerresponders.org dot uk
and do something this christmas
that you can tell your grandchildren
about many christmases from now
in total we've boosted more than 45 of
all adults in england including more
than 88
of those of those aged 70 or over
and while hospital admissions are going
up nationwide we're starting to see
admissions coming down
among some of the more vulnerable older
age groups where we've already got those
boosters in arms
from tomorrow we're speeding things up
even further by removing the 15-minute
post-vaccination waiting time
and while we're at it from monday
12 to 15 year olds can book in for a
second jab and we know how crucial it is
to keep children in school so let's all
make sure our children and young people
are vaccinated before they go back next
term
as we take forward our national mission
we're of course supporting similar
efforts by the devolved administrations
which are also rapidly increasing
vaccination rates across scotland wales
and northern ireland a cobra meeting
with edinburgh cardiff and belfast is
taking place this evening
but already
the pace of rollout across the four
nations
is such that the uk as a whole now has
twice as many boosters per head as the
eu and more than twice as many as the
united states
so let's keep going let's keep giving
omicron both barrels and let's
slow its spread
and give the vaccines more time
wear face masks indoors use ventilation
get tested if you're going to an event
where you're likely to meet lots of
people and get tested if you're going to
meet elderly or vulnerable relatives
and we're helping you to get the tests
that you need i want to thank the royal
mail who are doubling home deliveries of
testing kits to 900 000 a day from
saturday
so let's
slow
down omicron's speed and at the same
time let's reduce the harm omicron can
do to us by building up our vaccine
defenses we're jabbing in hospitals
we're jabbing in surgeries we're jabbing
in pharmacies and in pop-up centers
we're jabbing in shopping centers and on
high streets in football stadiums with
mass events planned at stanford bridge
and wembley this weekend and
daily jabathons at ellen road in leeds
we are throwing everything at it and
wherever you are
we'll be there
with a jab for you so please
get boosted now
thank you very much i'm going to ask
chris to do the slides thank you prime
minister first slide please
uh i'll start off uh with slides that
people have seen before the the updates
but i think there is an important thing
to point out on this slide
which is the very high uh spike on the
very fast far right of this slide
and as the prime minister said this is a
record number of cases i'm afraid we
have to be realistic that records will
be broken a lot over the next few weeks
as the rates continue to go up
if you look at the overall rates
it looks as if delta which we've had
with us for a while is still flat and
the growth is omicron so what we've got
is two epidemics on top of one another
an existing
delta epidemic roughly flat and a
growing omicron very rapidly growing
omnicorn epidemic on top of it next
slide please
when it comes to hospitalizations uh
this really always of course reflects
where we were two uh two or more weeks
ago and therefore the rates have
remained reasonably flat uh over quite a
while reflecting where we've been
with delta over the last several weeks
so rates are currently flat but they are
beginning to increase in some places
particularly in london
next slide please
and deaths of course reflect what
happened even earlier in time
and those are still if anything going
down very slightly but this of course
doesn't reflect anything in terms of
omicron because the emergence of omicron
and its spread is far too recent
next slide please
uh dr konani is going to talk more about
the vaccination in a minute but i just
wanted to visualize to give a visual
picture of the speed at which the
initial rollout that's in blue
the then uh the second dose which is in
orange and now the booster rollout
is occurring in red and as you can see
it's going up very rapidly and
accelerating and that will continue to
happen over the next period of time
next slide please
when i showed this slide the last
session people said they want a bit more
time on it and i want to make her two
points on it
what this shows is
what the hospitalization
rates
and different age groups where in
the dark bars are people who are not
vaccinated and the orange bars are the
people who are vaccinated with two doses
first point
this provides massive amounts of
protection against hospitalization
against delta this is what we're showing
but what we're expecting to happen with
omicron is that some of that difference
is going to be eroded
because it is less well the vaccines are
less well matched
to the omicron variant this is what the
laboratory data are implying we don't
have clear clinical data yet and
therefore the point of the booster is to
try and get people back to as good as
position in terms of replicating this
really good protection uh after they've
had their booster dose it will
additionally uh provide protection
against delta and other variants so that
is really what we're aiming to do but
this is you know when people say do
vaccines work i really do think if
people look at these data they cannot
really argue except that vaccines are
remarkable at working but people do
still go into hospital even when they're
double vaccinated and they will still
still go into hospital
even after boosters but their risks are
much reduced next slide please
now moving on to um omicron
and uh what i'm showing here is a
screening test from a cron these aren't
genotype things uh this is what's called
s gene target failure but it now nes
gene target failure pretty well uh
represents nomicon case and the reason
we're showing this is you get these data
earlier than you get the data from the
full genotyping so it's more up-to-date
now i'd like to uh point out two things
with this the first of which is the
count of numbers is now going up very
fast
um i'd like to point out also that the
grayed out bars those data are
incomplete and will increase
again i saw some commentary that said ah
that shows it's going away next time the
last bits of data and the same is true
in the uk it's also true incidentally in
south africa the last bits of data will
always increase as new data comes in
but both the numbers but also the
percentage of cases is steadily rising
so an increasing percentage of all of
our cases is now omicron but that's not
because delta's going away it's because
omicron's being built on top of that
next slide please
the final slide i wanted to show um is
really just to show that this is
happening across the whole of england it
is also uh happening very clearly in
scotland uh and beginning to happen in
wales in northern ireland but these are
data from england
in london now the majority of cases
uh in
london are going to be omicron
and therefore that is going to be where
we will be from the time we get to uh
probably christmas onwards i would
expect most cases going to hospital to
start to be omicron cases
i would like to make one final point
before i hand on over to dr kanani
because i think that there has been a
certain amount of commentary
about the fact that
doctors and scientists from south africa
and i really want to pay huge tribute to
south african science and medicine what
they've done so quickly has been
remarkable
have indicated that there may be some
reduction
in the hospitalization rates they're
seeing
with omicron and i want to put a really
serious caution on this because i think
it has been over interpreted
the first caution on this is simply a
numerical one
if the rate of hospitalization were to
halve but you're doubling every two days
in two days you're back to where you
were before you actually had the
hospitalization if the peak of this is
twice as great then halving of the more
the hospitalization rate you still end
up in the same place and this peak is
going very fast
but the second point i wanted to make
which i'm not sure has fully been
absorbed by everybody
is that the amount of immunity in south
africa for this wave
because of a prior delta wave and
vaccination is far higher
than it was for their last wave
and therefore the fact that there is a
lower hospitalization rate is
unsurprising
so if you think about what happened to
us in the uk
with our alpha wave in
january february this year
uh the infection hospitalization rate
the people over 65 was around 22
prior to vaccination
once you have a lot of immunity due to
primarily vaccination and then also some
natural infection the infection
hospitalization rate in the same age
group has dropped to six percent that's
just because there's more immunity
well there is more immunity in south
africa now than there was in their last
wave therefore some degree of drop is to
be expected now we that doesn't mean
that there isn't
some degree of
slightly milder disease that is possible
but i just think there's a danger people
have over interpreted this to say this
is not a problem and what are we
worrying about i want to be clear i'm
afraid this is going to be a problem
exact proportions of it of course south
african scientists and uk scientists and
scientists globally are trying to
determine at the moment
i'd like to just pass on for the last
slide to dr konamic nikki
nikki thank you very much thank you very
much um so there is clearly one single
challenge that our country faces right
now but we have two asks of you as a
member of the public one is please come
forward and get your booster and if
you're unvaccinated come forward and get
your first dose or if you're severely
immunosuppressed get your third dose